today on game life
I'm presiding over a retro game showdown
between Chris Kohler and legendary game
collector Mike mica I read he is not
ready so I asked the both of you before
we came today for each of you to bring
three games that weren't available in
retail stores and we're gonna put them
up head-to-head best of three wins I'm
gonna judge and I don't have a gavel but
I do have an actual literal hammer so
Peter these games are very valuable and
I want you to be careful I Wayne I
promise to bludgeon them gently if you
lose so let's begin
the Honorable Peter s Rubin is presiding
I would like to begin with I will begin
with the visitor Michael what's your
first
what's your first specimen so I I
brought something that's kind of close
to me because when I was younger there's
a game that I always dreamed of having
but it never really got released and
it's sword quest water rose Atari 2600
that was not the most pristine version
of the game this is a game that come out
and it was announced in the atari age
fan club magazine and i had played the
first two games and then ultimately
there would be a fourth game yeah come
out but Atari put the kibosh on on the
Perron the whole program got the first
two games out early the world and fire
world and those are very very common
yeah me find those anywhere yep but this
one not so much and I remember seeing
this at a closeout store when I was
younger and begging my parents for me to
get in there it was like $5 and they're
like no no and I'm like in my mind I'm
like mine actually met when I moved out
here had a few copies of this time
enough to give this to me when I first
came out to California and so it's been
in my question quite a bit now if you
get a shrink wrap version you can see
that for like four hundred dollars oh
yeah loose cartridge one hundred and
hundred fifty it's actually been coming
down Atari loose cart not to you know
disparage the sword quest Waterworld
here Atari loose cartridges have been
coming down in price recently but the
boxes and the manuals have been kind of
staying up there so it's good that
you've got the the complete version
exactly yeah yeah yeah okay well let me
answer let me answer that yeah what do
you have a fine entry with this so you
might say Chris
Mario's tennis for the for the Nintendo
Virtual Boy the rudimentary 3d aborted
game system that Nintendo put out for
less than a year before killing you
might say Mario's tennis came packaged
in with the Virtual Boy everyone has
this and you're absolutely right the the
difference is this has the Box because
the game that was packaged in with the
Virtual Boy was just a game in the
manual no cardboard box this box was
only made for blockbuster video and if
you rented this game from blockbuster
they had this box sitting on the shelf
and then when blockbuster and Nintendo
got rid of all of their inventory of the
Virtual Boy Blockbuster would actually
get rid of these boxes as well and sell
them to people how'd you come across
that this particular copy I think I
actually got in a you know video game
store I probably paid like $25 for less
but the box itself is worth about a
hundred and fifty bucks right now
Nintendo boxes alone for even NES and
Virtual Boy and all these thing the box
itself is going for so much money now
for all these games Oh totally yeah yeah
okay that's the first round and I like
sword quest a lot but I like the rental
exclusive even more so I'm gonna give
this round to Koehler yes however round
two I'm gonna give whoever lost the
round gets to begin the next round and
go and get okay and try to draw first
blood for that so let's let's see what
you got on this next one obviously I'm
an older gamer and Atari is a fetish of
mine obviously with like all the games I
produce for Atari and whatnot so this is
a lab loaner cartridge from Atari the
division at Atari of a game called
Donald Duck which is actually dumb bucks
speedboat right you know if you if you
can't see the date on this that is April
12 1983 yes from the prototype line and
so these were what they used internally
when they were creating and testing
games that's right and they would they
would hand these out externally to game
magazines were only like one or two at
the time right Rd club magazine that
sort of thing okay and they would ask
for them back it would say please return
to prototype labs sure of course um
there is a thing about this game this is
technically
yeah this game particularly did not come
out which follows the theme we're
talking about it's Dom ducks speedboat
it's a side-scrolling action game it
looked really nice it was part of the
whole Disney licensing program that they
had which had of course like Fantasia
Sorcerer's Apprentice game right and
that sort of thing very difficult to
find these right now and luckily I was
able to find this at a flea market here
in California stuff floats around the
person who was selling it to me had no
idea what this was and I felt kind of
guilty because they were actually saying
they would give me a discount because he
didn't have the labor oh and I mean what
was full price that they were asking so
this was $2.00 and they offered to give
you it to you for a dollar because it
didn't have the label that's right and I
gave them the $2 anyways cuz I said I've
been looking for it and it purchased a
total of ten of these from their same
lot and there's very interesting games
some of the most interesting ones there
and normally something like this goes
for upwards of 200 sometimes even more
especially this was never released it
was not released and it does have you're
right it has cross collectability
because there's no white and other games
are very valuable for Disney collectors
who collect anything Disney like it
could be a napkin or whatever and spent
a lot of money so this one is uh I like
it
as far as it's like rareness I like it
better than Waterworld I think it's a
pretty good contender for our little
battle that's pretty strong Chris Kohler
okay I'm gonna have to see what you
bring off but here's how I'm gonna
answer this if you like the rent you
know what I'm playing to the judge here
if you like the rentals let me show you
this is the only John Madden video game
that is worth any money whatsoever you
know typically your John Madden games
the Madden football for the Sega Genesis
they're worth basically nothing because
they made so many of them nobody really
wants to buy them and play them but
except for this one so if you see John
Madden Championship Edition you're gonna
notice down here it says rental store
exclusive so what we're dealing with
here is a version of John Madden that
you could only get at either like
Blockbuster Video or your local video
rental store really important about this
I want to point out the the cartridge
itself you can kind of find it's like 30
bucks or so you know the box might be a
little bit more expensive but this one
has a beautiful instruction man
inside sources here in store also says
rental store exclusive and the thing is
when people rented video games a lot of
video game stores just took the
instruction manuals and threw them away
because they knew they were gonna get
destroyed they make copies of them or
they make like those sort of instruction
sheets that they pasted onto the end of
the box
remember the little cardboard little
sheets that would tell you the brief
instructions yeah or they would put a
sticker on the instruction manual and
say don't steal this or it would just
get destroyed by the kids are thrown
away or whatever so to find a rental
store game that still has the
instruction manual in that good of a
condition is is really big and so this
is something that in this condition
would be worth about $100 or so and I
also found that at a flea market here in
the Bay Area okay so this is tight both
local finds both steals I'm gonna say
given a combination of rarity age and
the fact that it's technically theft
because it's still property of Atari I'm
gonna give this one to Mike for the
dollar speedboats also you know play to
the judge once is fine but you know
don't take advantage of my predilections
here no more rental store exclusive
we're all tied up this round so you
began ago first word final decisive
round this is not a rental store
exclusive and quite frankly I think I'm
doing pretty well with this last one so
this was something that was never
available in stores in this country
that's right so you might know Mike
Tyson's punch-out is one of the most
popular what and quite frankly for my
money one of the absolute best games of
a Nintendo Entertainment System before
they release it in America they release
it in Japan this happens a lot but this
game was never sold to anyone this was
only given out as a prize if you did
really well on a golf game for the
Famicom the Japanese version of the
8-bit Nintendo system you could take
your scores and send them into Nintendo
and the people who did the absolute best
on this game you had a chance of winning
a golden punch-out cartridge and now you
know you can find these in like
collectible stores in Japan
hundred hundred and fifty or so dollars
but this was never ever ever sold to a
single person ever how did you how did
you come upon this beauty I went to
Japan and bought it well the thing is it
was actually uh it was a lot it was
cheap because it has this cosmetic
damage here you see the rip in the label
and that in Japan is like the kiss of
death
so I actually paid about fifty bucks for
this but you know to have a copy that I
don't mind pulling out and like playing
if I really felt like it
there is no Mike Tyson in here by the
way right I was gonna say you get to the
point where you would fight Mike Tyson
and the game's over so it is slightly
different too but yes this is totally
one of the the center pieces of my
collection because a it's a game that I
really love and it's a it's a version of
that game that is very hard to get your
hands on that's great all of that is
tugging at this judges heartstrings and
all will be taken under consideration
this is an uphill road for you my friend
this is what you see what you got you
know I didn't know this one was coming
out but I did bring something that I
kind of kept off that I think is gonna
gonna help here so I have right here
half-life for Dreamcast Oh what is this
so it was planned to be released on
dreamcast never came out again following
this theme in fact like the actual disk
of the game was never truly manufactured
but there are versions of the game that
are out there people can play and this
this is not like a photocopy no this is
the real half-life this before - in fact
I will go even crazy and maybe oh my god
hurt you with this hammer
you sure can this is this was planned to
be part of the release and the disc
would come into this and they would
really sit out there okay the story goes
that there were probably about 500 of
these made many destroyed someone
managed to save a few of these and maybe
even two and that person will go unnamed
because he's always said do not ever say
my name okay he managed to give me one
of them and it's it's probably one of
the most prized possessions I have
that's amazing and you can see this was
ready to go to store it was ready for me
like it was oh you had a retail yeah and
includes the game included the
expansionpak thing was blueshift if I
remember correctly and it was actually a
pretty good game for Dreamcast it's just
a shame it never came out and if the
fans really wanted this game to come out
and say the only thing the only not
because there were some reviews for it
that come up because they were so close
to shipping it they'd only not get
really had was the load times I think
that was about it but they're normal
have you played it yes I have okay okay
just judge wants to know in terms of
value that is like that is the absolute
like highest value thing sitting on this
table and the thing is we would never
know how much it's actually worth you
can measure it you're right you would
have to sell it you would have put it up
for auction no no no and certainly not
recently yeah that's right I have not
seen any activity on it I've been
looking for a long time oh sure who else
would have this you want to know yeah I
just wanted to come and get a gauge for
like what is the perceived when you
walked in today with an assistant who
had a briefcase chained to their wrists
I didn't know what that was about now I
understand okay
so golden punch-out no Mike Tyson went
to Japan to get it like a lazy rube half
life for Dreamcast which I'm sorry this
is not even a contest I'm calling this
one for Mike that was it was
touch-and-go for a second I wasn't I was
not aware of this I was not aware of
this game and when you pulled that out
there was almost an accident you failed
me gold punch-out he failed me for the
last last time
thanks so much Mike for being here I'm
gonna put this hammer down now this has
been a pretty fantastic opportunity for
me to see some of these games I know you
have a bunch so you can subscribe to
Mike's channel on YouTube as well as
ours which we urge you to do now this
has been another game life video on the
wire channel you know I don't know what
my channel is